a key witness in the murder trial of a
former Dallas police officer is now dead
police are trying to find out who killed
him
Joshua Brown both of John's neighbor was
shot to death on Friday his testimony
you may recall helped prosecutors piece
together the events of John's murder and
ultimately led to Amber Giger's
Convention conviction rather Omar
Villafranca is in Dallas with more on
the story
Omar what are authorities now saying
about this latest death Dallas Police
are saying they're investigating the
shooting from Friday night at this
apartment complex behind me but so far
they don't have any motives and they do
not have any suspects now the attorney
for both of John's family is also the
attorney for the brown family and he
tells me that his client should have
been protected after testifying in the
amber Giger murder trial on the witness
stand
Joshua brown recalled feeling startled
when he heard the gunshots that would
ultimately take both of John's life now
the Jean family and their attorney Lee
Merritt are demanding answers to a key
witness suddenly be killed it's
suspicious
was this related to the trial there's no
clear indication of that Joshua Brown
took the stand in Geiger's trial and
gave emotional testimony about the night
both of John was killed last September
Brown said he was in the hallway when he
heard the two gunshots did you tell one
of the voices was getting loud to me if
I saw police or anything of that nature
the shooting that killed Brown happened
at a different apartment complex than
the one where Geiger and Jean lived
witnesses described hearing several
gunshots Friday night and seeing a
silver 4-door sedan
speeding away from the parking lot
Merritt says Brown was scared someone
was after him after he was involved in a
separate shooting incident in Dallas did
he fear for his life or lived to this
case or anything else in general he had
been shot less than a year ago and
someone standing near him was killed he
was reluctant to testify in this case
because he had been shot at and he
thought some people might want him to do
harm to him is there anything Police
Department could have offered any
protection if he had concerns for his
safety
then the city the county had an
obligation to ensure that those concerns
were met Brown was working in roofing
and property management at the time of
his death now
the Jean family has filed a civil suit
against the city of Dallas in the death
of their son both of John and Merritt
tells me that Joshua Brown would have
been one of the first witnesses called
to testify in that case Tony it is very
suspicious on why thank you very much